so as we debug the weight loss we look
for energy levels we look for sleep
problems we look for digestion and then
we are at cravings now cravings are a good
indication that there's something wrong
in the body that there's something missing and if
you're craving sweets you're not burning
fat you're burning sugar so this is a
very good indicator that we need to fix
it okay because when you're actually
burning fat you're not craving anything
so it just kind of it just tells us that
their diet isn't right yet so if they're
craving sweet that's a usually potassium
deficiency we need to have seven to ten
cups of vegetable per day to get rid of
potassium deficiencies but if they
already are eating potassium enough it
could be just a complete adrenal burnout
mainly the inside of the adrenal and
they need l-tryptophan to increase the
serotonin which is the pleasure hormone
yeah okay so we're just trying to go
trying to reduce stress and then we have
starches that would be like potato and
pasta and mac and cheese and all those
wonderful pleasure foods that people are
addicted to that's a B vitamin
deficiency so give them nutritional
yeast make sure the potassium is in
there as well but they might need
l-tryptophan to to increase serotonin -
given that comfort feeling and we might
even want increase dopamine to buy that
product that we talked about before but
start with this right here
now salt if they crave salt then we know
the adrenal is losing salt and salt
buffers the pH and it transports carbon
dioxide so it actually helps breathing
so we're not opposed to having a
consumed sea salt as long as they're
doing enough potassium so they need that
salt because it's going down so
sometimes if they're deficient in salt
they're going to be tired as well salts
electrolyte and salt could even be one
reasons one it could be cramping that's
a rare case but it can cause a problem
with that so make sure they're if
they're working out a lot and they're
sweating well they need more salt as
well now
if they create fatty foods deep fried
foods deep-fried catfish with tartar
sauce fried chicken I have a history of
craving fat not that ever give in to my
cravings but that means that the
person's has a liver gallbladder bile
thing they're not absorbing the fat
soluble vitamins thereby they're craving
more fat they're never satisfied so
again give them the bile and that will
handle it through the gallbladder
formula now what about chocolate we
don't they crave chocolate that would be
an L tryptophan thing given that and
that that will increase serotonin this
means the adrenal is needs more
serotonin becomes burnt out but you know
what magnesium actually is used to build
l-tryptophan so you could also give them
magnesium too for chocolate cravings okay
but again if you fix the adrenal you
just handled this one this one this one
and this one yeah okay sour if they
crave sour or lemon they have a choline
deficiency and they're what choline is
needed to make this neurotransmitter
called acetylcholine and acetylcholine
is essential for sleep and awake cycles
and also to support something called the
parasympathetic nervous system and
that's the system that helps you sleep
so the best remedy would be to give them
a lot of lemons and a lot of you can
even give them choline which is actually
a lemon tasting vitamin they'll suck on
it choline and they'll love it
the other thing that you can give them
is nutritional yeast to increase the
acetylcholine and that will help the B
vitamin given the B vitamins to make
more acetylcholine
but typically they'll crave sour to help
consume choline to actually strip off
the liver so people that have a fatty
liver will a lot of times crave sour
because they're trying to naturally eat
foods resolve and fight on the liver
now if they crave ice that's iron
deficiency so make sure the not anemic
or pregnant or whatever have a
digestive problem but usually if they're
pregnant they'll crave ice that's an iron
deficiency or they'll crave dirt so just
get go outside in the backyard and give
them a teaspoon of dirt okay
caffeine that is a you give them
recommend phenylpiracetam
that is a supplement they can get if you if they
want to come off caffeine I just
recommend and reduce it I don't always
recommend this but you if you need it
you can give it to them but when you
take caffeine from chocolate or from tea
or coffee it depletes calcium and b1
just FYI so just look for those
deficiencies they might show signs of
those deficiencies alcohol as a
substitute I like to give them kombucha
tea because that actually helps give the
same texture as beer and you can also give
them that Dopa Mucuna
which is that African bean
to actually help them come off alcohol
and drugs it's a very good thing because
it stimulates dopamine which is the
pleasure and reward system of the brain
now they're hungry all the time they
need more bile they need more fat
soluble vitamins because they're not
digesting fats MSG monosodium glutamate
we'll just increase potassium the
opposing mineral to help balance that
out and then you're just going to have
to educate them on what this is what
food that it's in and that this will
increase insulin by 300% so the food
manufacturing companies purposely put
that in the food to make you addictive
and they're tricking you and it makes
the food taste better than it really is
so they get away with selling
crap and makes it taste good
it's like crap that tastes good crazy
okay stress eater we have a lot of
stress eaters out there so a good remedy
would be Magnolia that's a product I
think it's called relora but just
look for a product that says Magnolia and
that's kind of like taking a chill pill
and it helps them every time they go
through stress okay so use this flow
chart for cravings and we'll go on to
the next factor